uh last week a former newsmax host and
right-wing uh shock jock as they're
calling him by the name of dick farrell
died
of covet
now farrell had spent a lot of time
during the pandemic trashing dr falchi
calling the entire pandemic a scam
democrat and essentially trying to
downplay everything downplay the
effectiveness of the vaccines casting
doubt on those
casting doubt on the pandemic itself
saying oh this is democrats trying to
control things
dies last week from kovid
but before he died
he had one of those come to jesus
moments that we have seen far too often
in the people who die from the vac
excuse me die from the virus
he texted his friends
telling them go get the vaccine
so here was somebody
who had devoted more than a year
of his media career
to try
to convince people that this wasn't real
that this wasn't a big deal that it was
all a scam
and the last thing he did on this earth
was tell his closest friends
it's real
protect yourselves
get the vaccine
now he's dead
we also had the story last week of scott
aptly
from texas republican official
on a county board from texas
he died of covid
he died a coveted five days
after posting anti-vaxx material on
facebook
left behind a young i believe infant son
left behind a wife
dead from covid
these stories
of people dying from covet after
spending a year and a half
pretending it didn't exist are becoming
far too common we are now at the point
where we're getting at least one per day
and a lot of them all in the same way
before the person dies they're tweeting
out they're texting out they're doing
whatever they can they're calling their
loved ones and saying please get the
vaccine
i can't believe i didn't do this i was
too stupid
some of them have said
and that really is what we're looking at
here folks
i'm willing to bet i would never have
agreed with anything dick farrell ever
said
ever
in his political career
and i still wish that that man were
alive today
same thing with mr scott aptly same
thing with all of these people
that are dying because they didn't want
to do the one thing that probably would
have saved their
lives every death is a tragedy
it doesn't matter if it's on the right
or on the left if it's a anti-vaxxer or
if it's a you know whoever
every death is a tragedy
and and it's unnecessary at this point
too
stories like this are hard stories like
this are getting very very hard to
report on but i do want to continue to
do this because hopefully they get
through to some people
hopefully this acts as the wake up call
when you hear these stories
of people gasping in their final breath
saying i wish i'd gotten the vaccine
asking their doctors
can i still get it
and the doctor having to tearfully tell
them i'm sorry but it's too late
that's the country we're living in now
and that's a country
that has been consumed with
misinformation
i'm farron cousins and for david pakman
we'll be right back